par le magazine l'étudiant vient de
sortir son traditionnel classement des
villes de france et tour est moyennement
juger mais il est assez facile d'y
trouver des explications regards des 21e
au palmarès des villes étudiantes tour
n'est pas franchement bien classée la
ville pourtant à la réputation d'être
agréable à vivre
alors qu'en pensent les principaux
intéressés rencontre avec des étudiantes
en psychologie
personnellement je trouve qu'une source
est vraiment propice aux études fin
après ça dépend la vie étudiante est
assez active au niveau de la place plume
havrais on a une fac plutôt bien situé
après ça dépend si des professeurs par
exemple pendant un an je vais pouvoir
faire de la danse à seulement 20 euros
par an donc pour 20 euros par an et je
peux faire aussi d'autres sports si je
le souhaite et le pack culturel ça coûte
7 euros ça nous offre beaucoup de
réduction tous les spectacles de théâtre
entrée au musée le du coup voilà c'est
intéressant il ya beaucoup d'étudiants
donc enfin on peut se rencontrer place
plumes
après c'est vrai que ça à voir vraiment
une motivation pour travailler soi même
parce qu'il ya beaucoup enfin mes tantes
et l'allée dans les bars d'aller faire
la fête mais après pas du tout souci chu
bien à toi
à regarder de plus près ce classement
tours est effectivement bien notées dans
de nombreux domaines par exemple le
logement les sports l'emploi étudiant ou
encore l'offre culturelle mais elle se
fait épingler sur le coût des transports
en commun ce qui explique cette très
moyenne 21e place au niveau des
transports moi je sais que j'aime chez
retrait la carte de bus c'était 10 euros
l'année donc moi ça me fait un grand
grand écart passer à 30 euros par mois
on est dans les deux ou trois villes où
les transports sont les plus chers et
c'est vrai donc du coup ça nous faire
perdre beaucoup de places c'est des
choses que nous avons relayé depuis
depuis longtemps depuis plusieurs années
pour que l'on puisse trouver une
solution à ces transports c'est
essentiellement évidemment avec fil bleu
et avec tours plus pour que
coûte moins cher le président rappelle
aussi que la population étudiante a
augmenté de 15% en sept ans et dans le
classement des grandes villes cette fois
celles qui comptent entre 20 et 40 mille
étudiants tour pointent à une sixième
place plus qu'honorable